suspense total dans la sphère fillon le
tribunal correctionnel de paris doit
rendre son jugement dans la sphère des
emplois fictifs de pénélope fillon un
jugement très suivie dans un contexte
tendu autour du parquet national
financier est la défense a demandé la
réouverture du procès pour faire la
lumière sur d'éventuelles pressions
pendant l' enquête
théo compte trois ans et demi après
laffaire fillon va être trouvé son
épilogue
rien n'est moins sûr au vu des derniers
rebondissements de cette affaire
politico judiciaire hors norme
révélée par l'hebdomadaire le canard
enchaîné
cette affaire d'emploi fictif avait
empoisonné la campagne présidentielle de
françois fillon en 2017
en six ans de vie politique 36 ans sans
jamais aucun problème d'ordre judiciaire
je suis aujourd'hui la cible d'une
attaque impitoyable partial 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24
et tout ceci pour des faits anciens
connus légaux est ce que c'est juste
est-ce que c'est équitable élections que
le candidat perdra finalement ne
franchissant pas le premier tour en mars
le parquet national financiers requiert
cinq ans de prison dont deux ferme et
375 mille euros d'amendé à l'encontre de
l'ancien premier ministre
son ancien suppléant à l'assemblée
nationale marc joulaud risque pour sa
part deux ans de prison avec sursis et
20000 euros d'amande
ils sont poursuivis pour détournement de
fonds publics et pour des prestations
fictives ou surévaluée des faits qui
concerne l'emploi de pénélope fillon
les pousses de l'ex candidat à la
présidentielle aperçue plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros d'argent
public pour un envoi de collaboratrice
parlementaire lorsque les deux hommes
furent successivement député de la
sarthe entre 1998 et 2000 13 une
rémunération conséquente pour un emploi
considéré comme fictif par l'accusation
pénélope fillon risque trois ans de
prison avec sursis et 375 mille euros
damende 2 au côté l'assemblée nationale
partie civile dans le procès réclame un
million d'euros de dommages et intérêts
une demande légitime pour les avocats de
l'institution et ce n'est pas une
première pour l'assemblée nationale que
de demander le remboursement de
rémunération qui serait considérée par
la justice
encore une fois son organe n'a pas de
pouvoir de police c'est l'application
d'une doctrine traditionnelle qui
s'applique de façon constante
ultime rebondissement le 10 juin
l'ancienne directrice du parquet
national financiers eliane houlette
affirme avoir subi des pressions de la
part de sa hiérarchie
pendant l' enquête et demande de
chronologie général tout ça à deux jours
d'intervalle awa trois jours demande
d'éléments sur les auditions demande de
notes des conseils avec des mises en
cause
réunion réunion j'ai été convoqués au
parquet général parce que le choix de
procédures de procédure soit procédural
que j'avais à adopter ne convenait pas
m'engager à changer de voie procédurale
à dire d'ouvrir une information et j'ai
d'ailleurs une dépêche j'ai reçu une
dépêche du procureur général en ce sens
oui on ne peut que se poser des
questions la décision est trop le trait
et 3,7 un contrôle très étroit et c'est
une pression très lourde des révélations
fracassantes qui ont poussé emmanuel
macron à saisir le conseil supérieur de
la magistrature pour qu'ils vérifient si
le parquet national financier avait bien
mené son enquête sans pression de
l'exécutif
autant d'éléments nouveaux qui pour la
défense des filles on justifierait la
réouverture du procès des événements qui
pourrait repousser le rendu du verdict
réponse aujourd'hui à 13h30